[Musique]
rencontrer les habitants de l'élément City
Air a généralement la tête dans le nuage
oh ma nouvelle veste La Terre peut être un peu
minable rien de bizarre ici euh juste un
peu d'eau d'élagage entre toujours
dans quelque chose
[Musique]
et le feu comme ordonné  nous courons un peu chaud
cette boutique est le rêve de notre famille un jour
tout sera à vous mais nous vivons tous selon
une règle simple
les éléments ne peuvent pas mélanger la
pipe m'a écrasé tout hors de forme
c'est mieux oh
donc tu n'as jamais quitté firetown  désolé
les éléments de mon pote ne se mélangent pas
plus mon père te ferait bouillir vivant pourquoi
est-ce que quelqu'un peut te dire ce que tu peux
faire dans ta vie
pourquoi ont-ils même ces oui qui
sait
[Musique]
souviens-toi que je vois un changement en toi
quel type de cheveux  tu vis ici c'est chez ma
mère nous avons deux enfants qui
nagent ici quelque part
j'ai essayé de mettre les chaussures de mon père
une fois demandé ce que je voulais faire
essayer ce papa ils sont trop chauds j'aime la
nourriture chaude
[Musique]
toi  tu vois il aime ça